fourteen-year-old powerhouse singer
Courtney had wind back on the AGT stage
slaying this time for America's Got
Talent the champions her second chance
at taking the top prize do you feel like
you're getting used to all of this
attention and all this kind of response
for your voice
we met Courtney last summer when she
appeared on season 13 of AGT she was
Howie's golden buzzer everyone thought
the shy girl with the big voice was an
easy frontrunner to win what would it
mean to you to make it to the finale it
would just mean everything together to
get he is just amazing the semi-finals
so to be able to get to the finals it's
a dream come true leaving the
competition
Courtney had one it felt really pop this
time Courtney sang in her signature
style but with a twist she performed an
original song
[Music]
[Applause]
the judges and audience went wild for
Courtney's performance which landed her
a spot in the top three of the night but
unfortunately it wasn't enough for
Courtney to move on to the finals
finishing in third place is et sat down
with Courtney in August when she opened
up about performing and proved once
again she's mature beyond her years but
all of a sudden the music hits and you
become possessed I mean do you feel like
yourself up there did you go do you
transport to another place and channel
people like Janis Joplin it's like when
I'm off stage and nervous to go on and
then when I go on stage like everything
goes blank and still the music I just
think that I should be in the
competition to have fun and whatever
happens happens for a reason
[Music]